all right hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday September
now February 12th there's a [ __ ] ton
I don't know whether I know where the
[ __ ] I am February 12 2018 what's going
on how are you usually usually I do
these by myself
usually I'm just sitting alone but it's
like you know what [ __ ] this my buddy
called me up he's got a podcast he wants
to promote and he's a [ __ ] Eagles fan
so I figured why not I got to go on
because for some reason people think I
actually [ __ ] hate Philly just
because I got booed there because of
that video yeah it's just like no I got
booed in Philly [ __ ]
if he got booed in Texas what do you do
you make fun of [ __ ] pickup trucks
chicks with too much makeup all of it
you just make fun of Texas in general I
think everyone just goes to Texas my
goal to stay is Kentucky I like tell its
Kevin Shea everybody from the Kevin Shea
podcast still all I'm saying podcast all
I'm saying
let me that's that's easy right remember
law do you know every host and it also
kind of gets you off the hook or
whatever you just said exactly there's
too many people
I didn't specifically pick out that
group like they needed to go but there's
too many [ __ ] people everyone every
host [ __ ] it up though it's kind of
funny cuz I go they go what's your intro
all I'm saying podcast all I'm saying
all I'm saying I said you can easy
they ask two more times before they go
onstage
and they go all I'm talking about what
you doing how's it going and so we know
you didn't like you know sassy
yes and we always bet look at all I'm
saying isn't really that's that's pretty
mainstream vernacular I you know I
didn't I thought it was I [ __ ]
getting a title's heart like you you
have the best title ever it's just doing
it yeah it's simple it's so simple
that's why I did it is that why you
remember when it would come out funny
and then people go we should do one
every day of the week it's like well
then it's not the money
you got the thirst I do the third but
the others day just before Friday at
Monday morning podcast I love when
people just they go [ __ ] all out
yeah like you show up at some time some
of these comics studios you feel like
you're doing Howard Stern I you don't
want to be like dude you could really
keep your overhead wait I look I'm not
talking about guys like Rogen like Rogen
in will have like you know [ __ ] super
super famous but yeah I'm just talking
just like well does it mean to jerk off
like me and I'm having you over there
reason why you're not in my house right
now is because my daughter's I figured
that I figured cuz your daughter's sleep
in this yeah and then I didn't I didn't
know you moved like when you texted me
the studio I know but when you text me
let me yeah it's this no you you when
you texted me I was like why would he
move to Burbank I was like that's my I
was like pill I was like you're doing
well you got you got more bang for get
more bang for my buck out why would you
move I like the valley
I like the valley you know you're
getting better better conversations out
here you don't I mean you meet some guy
you did something on mash way back in
the day a bunch of Trump supporters you
know well then the Hillary stuff gets
old man in Hollywood it's like I get it
I get it you know what I mean I want to
hear it I want to hear somebody actually
thinks something Goods going on every
day breathe takes better this taco taste
better I don't I don't really talk to a
lot of people you know that about me
well then why did you come down well for
you it's just because your team just won
the Super Bowl the EAG
le s by the way I can't even my [ __ ]
huge Eagles fans but I hate that [ __ ]
song the fight song flowers oh I don't
know fly it has to be old right it's not
it's [ __ ] not I did a whole research
I thought it was from like 1920 or yeah
cuz it's not fly eagles fly when I see
that sounds like it was written the same
week of for he's a jolly good fellow
back when that wasn't corny to say it's
it's weird cuz it's supposed to sound oh
he's got the boom boom boom like the
jumps up front and goes am I hit him low
so looked it up razzamatazz 20 1985 or
something like me that is like 30 years
ago
32 years ago put it this way usually if
you were in 1985 right now and that song
was 32 years old they would have been
written in 1953
[ __ ] but I gotta be honest you hit him
high hit him low is very like still like
that sounds like it's written in the 40
it sounds very college no not knowing
college like high school I would say
college don't be too to her oh no I I
love the song
I love his thing it's it's one of those
songs where I love it but I acknowledge
his corny no Jimmy it's cheesy but I
love his it fly eagles fly up to the sky
there like a disco remake [ __ ] sink
the putt he's a jolly good fellow stay
he goes won the [ __ ] Super Bowl
remember when we were going to Brea it
is like years ago
to walk all of those gigs out drives me
hate those [ __ ] guys know i'm i swear
to god dude i almost like was ready to
[ __ ] just leave LA yesterday no way i
did i did that it was like [ __ ]
saturday it was a Saturday afternoon and
I was I can rush hour traffic and you
want to get mad but you're gonna be like
well I'm also out here and they're all
do this [ __ ] nobody is [ __ ]
talking about doing something about this
population problem and I'll tell you one
thing we have to get a problem of is
touching the desk and hitting this this
is gonna be annoying in this we have a
new podcast studio [ __ ] what are we
doing that no I I just I've been hearing
it so like we're gonna have to put some
sort of padding here I don't know what
but anyways I like nature right I
enjoyed like watching animals in that
type of [ __ ] but I always have my mic I
never take the remote out of my hand
when I watch a nature show because right
when they start talking about what's
going on with them and how they're all
gonna die off because of us I shut it
off well my daughter always you know
takes the remote and it's amazing my
[ __ ] remote sucks
I can literally be pointing at the TV
like change change change what the [ __ ]
I won't do anything my daughter picks it
up and is like walking away with it a
host will somehow turn on the [ __ ]
DVD player I still have one of those is
it digital the remote is the remote all
digital with like no I have DIRECTV and
I love DIRECTV but their remote sucks
you look at it you have to [ __ ]
reboot the thing it's like it's like it
like it was in an abusive relationship
it's oversensitive I feel like it was
recycled I'm like some racist had it
before me was constantly throwing it at
the TVs funny and then they just like
you know like all our old phones that
you watched a bunch of porn on now over
there in like Thailand the Philippines
do you know I eat dude you do you have a
have a laptop that I use just report is
proof ourselves just just the hard drive
so made out of latex it's just so own
and shot so I don't give a [ __ ] if it
gets diseases okay it stays separate but
it's old it's big
you know what that reminds me of you
ever see these people that get like
foster kids and they feed their their
real kids and they just take the checks
for the foster kids maybe the kid oh
look like he's [ __ ] eight years old
and really boning you'll be a cow old
and he's like 26 like [ __ ] paste and
[ __ ] but here's was confusing when I was
younger I'm adopted I never doesn't
surprise me I did irritated I don't know
the difference I didn't know the
difference between foster and adopted so
you thought that was like foster a kid
means uh you just take him for a little
while right yeah but but they were
always like abused you know I was never
abused and I couldn't rack my brain as a
kid I called my parents mom and dad but
then my friends down the street who were
a family but they were divorced with
kids called him by their [ __ ] names
well it's right there that's why they
got a divorce
zel and we never committed they weren't
committed to each other they weren't
committed to having the kids but I think
it's weird like when they would call
their mom by their first name well might
well my daughter learns how to speak I'm
gonna be like this is mr. Shea she's not
gonna call you Kevin I don't like that I
[ __ ] can't stand when people do like
my buddies will talk to their other
parents and they say hey John alright
Paul it's weird it would help if we kind
of dress like adults though
[Laughter]
you got a hat there you go you're an
adult there you go
it's not you know I know you know what
it was though no but back in the day
like you know people just to [ __ ]
like if you want I was I tape recorded
all like they had all the NFL Films
Super Bowls in a row on NFL Films and I
taped all 51 of them and I'm just
working my way through them I love them
I can't get awesome they're awesome so I
was watching them and first of all like
the first like 11 Super Bowls were
played in like the afternoon I know
they're playing like rice stadium not
Tulane
you know what I mean and there was just
like I got like a [ __ ] college band
like one of them like the Michigan
marching band that's so fun out there
and play I thought you were scatting
horn my [ __ ] head okay the Niners you
know they played in Golden Gate Park
remember for the European ships and
probably an NFL champ but you guys
sucked back then so I don't know I think
you had like one good year in the 40s it
was one it was one in the 50s and then
1960 was the last one and we used to we
always get into this discussion about
like you think it matters what that NFL
champion NFL titles should count they do
count but they're not Super Bowls and
you know I don't get that I you know boy
there was no other league I get it I get
it but now there is another league
there's no there's still there was there
was there was still a [ __ ] no you
don't understand the AFL started in 1960
before then there was there was only
need no there was the NFL and then the
AFL came in I'll give you a little
history on the first year the AFL okay
all the NFL owners laughed ba ha ha ha
ha look at these [ __ ] morons wasting
their money but while they laughed at
him they then they made two moves to
[ __ ] over the AFL the first thing they
did was that the team with the most
amount of money was was that was the
Dallas Texans they will red and white
right they lady became the Kansas City
Chiefs so what the NFL did was
immediately or
gave Dallas and NFL franchise that's how
the Cowboys started that started so that
there would be a team in the same city
as the wealthiest AFL team they're
trying to cut the head off the snake
here so then basically the figuring both
they're gonna be low quality of players
because they're both brand new however
you could see Jim Brown or whoever like
the superstar the day was would come in
and play the Cowboys you're gonna go
that game rather than the Dallas Texans
and it kind of worked because the Texans
ended up moving to Kansas City and
became the Chiefs all right then the
other move they made was one of their
franchises the Minnesota Vikings were
initially going to be an AFL team and
they came in and they said hey you want
to join the NFL and then they said hey
[ __ ] the AFL let's go with this team so
that's what they tried to [ __ ] over to
teams that's what they did
now the NFL continues there's all these
[ __ ] Championships being won the
Green Bay Packers won like [ __ ] 13 of
them and they're the New York Yankees
they're the [ __ ] Celtics they're
though they're the Montreal Canadiens of
football but they just don't recognize
their first 12 so they say the Steelers
are was six Super Bowls so in 1919 69
when the Jets beat the [ __ ] no Colts
was it cold they beat the Colts and
there was a merger talk was already
there and the AFL was actually doing so
well and was such an exciting product
that it was kind of looking like they
may actually might take over the NFL all
right and the only guy who had the balls
to say [ __ ] the new NFL that merger deal
was was was what's his face there Jesus
Christ just based on his name with the
Raiders
oh I'll date al Davis Al Davis does [ __ ]
dead he just didn't want to beat him he
wanted to bury him he wanted to put him
out of business and everybody else is
like now [ __ ] that let's join so they
joined
okay now that has happened in other
leagues the NHL with like the IHL with
Wayne Gretzky's where the [ __ ] he played
with India Indianapolis like I guess I
was his first team I used to know all of
this [ __ ] but they they've absorbed
teams from other leagues
the NBA took in ABA teams but they they
but they still count the Celtics
championships but they didn't change the
name of the title I think it's because
of
Oh changing the name of the title maybe
that's what it is I have a daughter's
because it's that you're changing the
name of the title the basketball never
changes me with it but is it thing the
first to Green Bay one how with the NFL
AFL championship game as was the third
one which would Jets the Jets was away a
fellow title game which is great but you
know what's funny about the whole story
you heard you just you told me no just
thinking oh my god the mic is still suck
but yeah do you know the Patriots now
have tied they've lost the most Super
Bowls but they also there's also the
thing is we've also been to the most
you've been a [ __ ] ten we're five and
five your you've been a 10 here's the
thing I say it's not an Ellen felt fan
out there that wouldn't take that except
for this fearless the Steelers
or the 49ers in the the 49 s and the
Cowboys because they already have five
and they better like eight or something
Nevers been five Denver lost five
there's one three eight the Cowboys have
won five and they'd see they lost to the
cults they lost to the Steelers twice I
think that's I think they've been to
eight do you I saw your clip Onan and
you go oh I've been through five of
these losses I'm like how old are you
because the first Patriots Super Bowl
was 86 okay that makes sense because I
am old I'm turning 50 in June I turned
42 on Friday of America you look great
thank you thank you considering how much
both of us drink I mean I like yeah
we're both in good shape I know
this is podcast so anyways before we get
into your big win because I really
because I'm gonna be honest with you I
actually as its pasta I'm old enough to
remember when all the Boston teams
sucked except for the Celtics
ladies but then Len Bias died and Reggie
Lewis die Atlanta was just [ __ ] over
I remember what it felt like the first
time so I was actually when the Patriots
were not looking good to me mm-hmm okay
you know when we played the Steelers and
we had the game won and we let up that
90 we let up
yards on a screen pass and then the
first year they want no this year this
year this year in December we did that o
against the playoff team and then they
threw a touchdown to win the game but
the NFL now is like oh when he had the
ball did you really have the ball so
it's not a catch but I was that game was
a [ __ ] loss and that gave us
home-field advantage and that helped us
[ __ ] go to Super Bowl yeah so here
was the thing my I was kind of watching
you guys yeah cuz I was just go right
well Who am I gonna root for I was like
LA Rams would be cool they got something
the [ __ ] Eagles would be cool because
they never won up so here's the thing if
my team isn't [ __ ] in it I'm gonna
root for the team no not a dick alright
so but you know if it's the Yankees [ __ ]
the Yankees if it's the Canadians [ __ ]
the eight Canadians and if it's the
Lakers [ __ ] the Lakers but other than
that I gotta ask you why the Canadians
Oh Bruins Canadians is okay okay used to
be a huge rivalry and what happens is is
one team never wins it and then the
other team always wins it and then then
what happens is then you win it and
that's the end of the movie then the
credits are rolling like they try to
make like the red sox-yankees thing
that's not the same no it's over and
it's kind of like you know when they
make the sequel but the star in the
movie doesn't sign on to do it again
yeah or bike back in the day with it
like a movie like major league - without
Wesley Snipes
they took omar epps / tall he was out
well I would say at major league without
Charlie Sheen okay the third or Jaws 3-d
jost just to the second spielberg goes
now I'm not doing it it just became a
became was that that what was the one
where the shark started roaring that was
the third one right it was gone
that's bad okay that's bad Aaron you
knew that yeah that's hilarious he's
just he was still immediate with the
floor that's why that's so [ __ ] funny
everybody looks at sharknado like it's
this worst thing ever it's like don't do
that the groundwork had been laid but I
like that movies well let me put the
skip back this rocket celsa I so I was
gonna sit there and you know you know I
got a lot of friends yourself yeah like
I have a good half-dozen people that I
know that are from Philly you know I
there's a lot of cool chicks and Phil
to you philia cool yeah so I wasn't
gonna be that [ __ ] you know [ __ ] so
anyway so you guys beat us and now you
know the deal you lose a big game like
that you go on radio silence I'm not
going on [ __ ] the Internet I mean I
kind of still have to cuz vodcast but
I'm not gonna watch he is peeing so I
didn't get to see you guys my favorite
thing ever is is [ __ ] grown men
crying over sports the funniest like
that Eagles fan who called them with
Carson Wentz went down did you hear that
sportscaster gets like freaked out he's
okay he's like buddy you're crying he's
like we're the next year man relax so
far did you see the guy who was waiting
at the fence when they won the Superbowl
and when they're landing just to watch
he was crying who's like a 54 year old
black dude just sobbing black guy yeah
sobbing he's just like my whole life my
whole [ __ ] life and my way and here's
they ate that Patriots I got hurt way
less now they kind of got me and that
hurts way less now knowing that somebody
an Eagles fan ended up being that
[ __ ] half oh come on man we [ __ ]
we're drowning in rings over here but
here here's then your first one you know
you was at the game I shut the [ __ ] up
you know people were losing it again you
know and when I everybody like we were
in the exact opposite end zone and he
like kicked a field goal and I'm alright
I put my hands out like I was holding
back the crowd on Beatlemania and my row
cuz my brother and dad was like [ __ ] and
it went through and just I see I was I
couldn't believe it when I went through
then I saw the confetti and dude all of
a sudden next thing I knew I was on the
ground what just a whole section just
tackled each other [ __ ] insane that's
[ __ ] and then I was worried about my dad
cuz I was there my dad and he was like
in his 60s at the time and he got up and
he just he couldn't [ __ ] believe it
right and I looked over and there was
one guy still standing up yeah and he
was just standing and I looked over him
he was for some reason staring at me and
he just had tears in his eye and I eyes
kind of locked I had to like look away
like dude what the [ __ ]
I remember walking out of the stadium
like just because I went to that when we
when we lost to the Packers so I know
what that feeling feels like and then
when I want it but that wasn't close
though that one it was until the opening
of the half so - had - so I basically
had faith through [ __ ] 18 and a half
games so yeah it was close and then they
kicked the [ __ ] ball off and Tyrone
Howard I know only kicker - one [ __ ]
MVP kick returner yeah so he ran the
[ __ ] thing back right at us that's I
might have been in the same endzone I
don't know why both times I had
upperdeck endzone seats so then when we
want it I was thinking like every time
the Patriots go I'm going and such a
great experience so the next time we
played I believe you were playing the
Panthers and I was gonna go but it was
on Sunday obviously and then that Monday
we were shooting the world series of
dice sketch in the morning for
Chappelle's Show
okay so I couldn't go and I went there
and that's the first time I met Charlie
Murphy rest his soul
and I'm being pissed that I was psyched
I had the acting work obviously it's
like to be on the Chappelle show but I
was like [ __ ] man I really want to go to
that game but I remember when the game
was over yeah and I was in my apartment
we won I was psyched that I still had
two grand in my pocket I was like wait a
minute
this is kind of [ __ ] cool so then I
was just like yeah I don't need to go I
saw the first one ever
yeah why am I gonna go there and use up
a ticket somebody else could have and
like someday you know if I have a kid
now I have a kid if she ever wants to go
I'll take her and I'll do that but other
than that you know I'm on the road all
the time do you did you you obviously
got the feeling I don't I don't know if
I'd be like if I was at this Super Bowl
my buddies went they lost they lost
their minds but they actually came back
immediately and watched the game because
they said they couldn't really believe
it yeah they can't believe it one or two
they didn't really see what was going on
well you don't get the analysis and the
breakdown and all of that let me ask you
this when when Brady fumbles the ball
and you guys recover
dude aha what did you do dude but by
thinking like [ __ ] he's gonna drive down
the field we're gonna lose no no no III
never this is just crazy
normally with all the egos teams oh my
god they don't got it something right
that weird stomach feeling uh-huh but
this team it was just this this year and
I sound destiny they lost their [ __ ]
quarterback I'm getting misty-eyed
thinking about it but then I was like
it's not about Tom it's about the Eagles
that's how I felt this year about this
team so when I didn't like how you guys
all ran out as a team and everything
will show a new girls like we've been
doing it stolen by that was our thing by
the way I think that's stupid
what year you guys did it to now I think
it's stupid
I loved the intros I kind of miss it was
like but I got to tell you dude we went
we've we've gone we've gone five and
three doing it that way and we've been
to eight of them so you might want to
keep doing it you know else was driving
me nuts was Chris Collinsworth flick
flipping out about that trick don't we
just ran that [ __ ] play but here's
they I saw I saw that clip and you uh
when you were calling you said I wished
I would have laid out I wish he caught
it and the only reason cuz I want to get
in I want him to get hit oh my gosh can
I be honest with you yeah that guy every
[ __ ] Super Bowl has driven us down
for the win everyone you know I actually
looked at all the Super Bowls and I
would say that we very easily could have
been seven and one and the one game we
should have lost was the Seattle guess I
should just giving it to Marshawn Lynch
both Giants games we had Brady a Welker
boom first down over Asante Samuel
intercepts the [ __ ] ball that hits
them in both hands we got that one but
that a saute Samuel but this Eagles one
I minded I was pretty [ __ ] John by
the end of the game and I just I'll tell
you I never felt good about this I'd
never felt good about the team or the
game going and I I said I believe I said
on my podcast take the Eagles on the
point on the points yes yes yeah and I
thought you guys I thought I've had an
unbelievable defense I like these guys
this is looking like the [ __ ] guys do
where was the defy out of that game it
was like a [ __ ] Pro Bowl by the way
I've watched the game four times
afterwards
just to watch it only Tom could have
done that
I guess that defense you know what's
funny only time I was as I was watching
some of those [ __ ] passes and how he
got out of pocket only tom could have
done that well against that defense
because most most ly most I'm happy to
whine I'll have to watch it again
because I didn't think you guys do it I
thought both quarterbacks had like all
day anything you've really got to
breathe
[ __ ] Nick Foles had all day Tom got
hit like 12 times but your line was
better than most
yeah dude didn't have a DJ I I would
never question our coaching staff the
mouth but anytime we do that I'm at that
time Wes Welker like made all that
movement when what's-his-face finally
had the foot fetish Rex Ryan he so
welcomed us this whole interview like
sort of giving him chicken you know hey
we're just uh you know you're playing
the Jets what he says yeah we're going
to put our best foot forward and you
know yeah it was funny and then they
kept him out for the first quart anytime
we do that I don't know if we've
probably done that other times but they
just reminded me of that game be like
our [ __ ] with the chemistry here but
but I'm a stand-up comedian Kevin I'm
not a [ __ ] offensive coordinator so
what our defensive coordinator what do I
know well I watched that game four more
times like I said oh it's the best dude
I still have the [ __ ] Seattle in the
Atlanta you still you still on my [ __ ] I
still have it I bought and I got the
thing never a race and my wife's like
you're never gonna watch she's like yeah
I'm you are more you will when you're
bored you want to get your [ __ ]
spirit so as she goes to bed early
dude I I'm never gonna watch this I just
taped the highlights of all 51 fun it's
like there's five losses in there well
four losses now we got a fifth one and
I'm still gonna watch those no it's it's
the best by the Super Bowl twenty we
were up three nothing against the 46
defense Tony Franklin speaking of feet
his bare feet came out kicked one and
I'm like yeah you know I don't there's
and talking all this [ __ ] I'll do that
that was the most dominant defense that
I ever saw here's a good one Super Bowl
six overall 6 is the Dallas Cowboys and
the Miami Dolphins what's interesting is
Tom Landry and Don Shula two legendary
coaches but when that game
went down they were both considered
losers and and like one of them's
finally gonna get their monkey off the
back Dallas had the thing they could
never win the big one and they'd only
been around since 1960 but they lost the
ice bowl up in Green Bay I know dude I'm
a [ __ ] nerd yeah and then the year
before they played the Colts they got
there again and they [ __ ] loss to the
Colts in a really messy game and then
Don Shula his big thing was he was what
he was coaching the 69 Colts that lost
to the Jets the first NFL team to lose
to an AFL team was a major embarrassment
and that ended his career there and then
he went over to the Dolphins no no they
went they went three years in a row one
of I think two teams to ever go three
years in a row and only one has ever
gone four years in a row and that's the
bills they lost to the Cowboys and then
the next year they beat the that they
beat the red yeah they beat the Redskins
that was the undefeated year that was
the year that they hadn't beat four
there was 14 to nothing and they were
lining up to kick a field well this is
how much the NFL has changed it's like
there's like two minutes left in the
third quarter and if this thing goes
through they're like the gut announcers
are going this game's over yeah cuz no
one's gonna score that because dude all
I did was [ __ ] run because they were
like greasy was 4 for 4 in the first
quarter that's funny do you know what I
love I love the fact that back then how
much cocaine those guys did do you heard
you ever see that cocaine Cowboys and
the one there's not a movie it was a
documentary it was about you know the
cocaine chapter what the cocaine in the
Superbowl it wasn't about cocaine
trafficking cocaine trafficking okay
they remember telling this story about
the Steelers and the Dolphins in the AFC
Championship game or Steelers in the
Super Bowl in Miami that entire line
went out the night before and the guy
gave them all the coke they wanted it's
also a jailbird trying to get into a
[ __ ] documentary right no no he was
he was the main guy well here's the
thing though they also like the medical
industry whatever they call him said
cocaine is no more addicting than coffee
or caffeine yeah so that's what they
initially said if you ever want to read
an unbelievable book read the
Hollywood Henderson he was basically the
Lawrence Taylor before Lawrence Taylor
and he got crazy on drugs and the reason
why Lawrence Taylor looks like he just
fell out of the sky and no one ever
played the game like that is because
Hollywood Henderson messed up his career
so bad but there's highlights of that
guy that guy was unbelievable in fact I
believe Super Bowl 10 1976 when he
played when the Cowboys played the
Steelers they kicked the ball off he's a
linebacker they had him return it and he
ran it like 55 [ __ ] yards the only
person who stopped and was roid Joella
dole to knock him out of bounds and had
his ribs exposed and Henderson's knees
hit him in the ribs and it [ __ ] him up
and it caused Joella this really
interesting caused him to [ __ ] up a
couple of kicks so that was a big thing
for the Cowboys but they [ __ ] up
because on the second miss or something
or the first a second miss cliff Harris
from the Cowboys gets injured out
Roger Allers face go like yeah you
[ __ ] up buddy and Jack Lambert was on
the field and just picked [ __ ] cliff
Harris up like a rag doll and threw him
under the ground like basically that's
amazing yeah and didn't get a penalty
there's enough time to watch those old
high like that yeah back then hey now
get off fellas yeah yeah helmets they
got it Sears Brian Dawkins is videos of
him suplexing guys well here's the thing
the Cowboys had that [ __ ] game won
they in the first half they call all
these trick plays they were loose they
were throwing the ball doing all that
they got in the second half they played
[ __ ] Marty ball on you man yeah no
[ __ ] sport [ __ ] you more when you
play not to lose than football I don't
know what it is as soon as the Falcons
are doing yeah a great granted Tom play
the [ __ ] lights out but you don't
dude that's a that's a colossal it's a
collapse
it's a collapse I mean you know more
about football history I'm more recent
but I don't know [ __ ] about football
I've just watched a lot of video on it
like I watched Super Bowl highlights the
way Tom Brady actually watched his game
film I don't want it here's the thing I
like Carson Wentz and you must love Tom
Brady I don't want to see their personal
life I don't I got give us no I'm not
built that way I don't like pre or post
game analysis yeah I don't like any of
that [ __ ] I don't want I don't want a
[ __ ]
get about to go no but I don't want a
human moments I don't this isn't some
funky I don't wanna see him as human I
just want to see him as athletes here's
the thing I think they're entitled to
their privacy I don't that you shall be
able to go out as an NFL quarterback and
if you want to go out and do some blow
and it's in a titty bar yeah this is
what I can't stand about [ __ ] people
today with their phones if they saw the
local quarterback doing blow in a titty
bar he's [ __ ] rather than thinking
well [ __ ] I'm here too you know what I
mean no I can't will literally film the
[ __ ] guys you know oh my god it can't
blue there's our starting quarterback
it's like what do you do yeah we work
with heavy machinery yeah what the [ __ ]
do you do your [ __ ] you're in the titty
bar to end this didn't like the whole
like just let somebody go out have a
good [ __ ] politician sounds like
there's everybody telling on everybody
just they're just so [ __ ] mad being
Jimmy John's managers and [ __ ] it's just
like the guy if you can be a Jimmy
John's manager and you can have a hell
of a [ __ ] exactly you could tell a week
you could have a [ __ ] weekend that
would make Tom Brady be like get the
[ __ ] out of here
well Tom doesn't do that Tom's I doing I
mean he's not going on and getting
[ __ ] nuts no I'm not staying here I'm
saying he should be able to I second you
said that all I thought about was Ken
Stabler I heard this great story used to
play for the Oakland Raiders before that
horrific trade where they got Dan
Pastorini and they switched him both and
he became an oiler and finished up at
the Saints I believe and he foolish
that's today yeah yeah no I that's all I
did was look at football cards back then
so his coach was giving him [ __ ] one
time cuz he went out boozing the night
before yeah he's just like eh what the
[ __ ] he going on about partying the
night before you have a game he just
goes coach he goes how many hours sleep
you need to go play a couple hours
football and there's nothing to say
you're right you're right those guys
used to go out there and they would just
[ __ ] swing it like I don't know so
anyways real quick how far into this
hour half hour [ __ ] at some point I got
to read some advertising so when they
finally [ __ ] win it are you with the
other Eagle fans you're crying to get
are you in stunts I'll buy yourself
where'd you watch the game out of do you
remember that casino we played in San
Diego we flew in the helicopter it's
North yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh you
were there so we were there the girl I'm
dating the girl I'm saying the lady
friend she's like I know you're not
gonna want to be around anyone so I'll
get your hotel so she got a solo tell
and then she's like I wanna sit by the
pool so I read Minister cuz cabana with
the TV it was [ __ ] awesome we had a
whole entire Cabana just to herself I
don't put any pressure on the
relationship but you got to marry that
guy I couldn't believe it she goes she's
a Steelers fan she loves football too
but she goes I get it she goes this is
your [ __ ] day she said I understand I
know I could how many times you said to
a woman I get it and you were right and
you made that day no I'm telling you
what she when I said to I find a woman
that gets it and I wholly said so I go
you can totally buy my love I'm all I'm
all for it
so I never day drink classic guys she
does something great yes there was
something sweet yeah a poker ish maybe a
little bit a little bit so I I don't
every day drink that's one of the
reasons why the Rose Bowl thing is out
the window cuz I I'll get my turn you
see me when I'm drunk do you think
that's why you've never been what do you
mean because the reason well they're
actually I'm gonna come clean okay we've
never had you there well the first
couple years know you've never been
there no no I'm saying the first couple
years you say hey come I said I think I
got to know you better I told you and
then we had a talk me and Bart nerd yeah
we're like listen we love che but that
year we bring che is the year we get
kicked out yeah in the first quarter and
I and I admit I told you guys that I
even told for tonight I go Bart in it if
you if I come and I'm started drinking
at ten oh it's done ten so we say seven
we get thrown it starts how the [ __ ] do
you mean go to the game I'm always blown
dude I literally drink pass out wake up
with a hangover and recover before the
game even starts I still can't believe
it's Sunday that's amazing I always fall
asleep when when lie had lied always
make some [ __ ] insane like for the
main course I never make it to the main
course I always wake up I always wake up
it's already over I mean one year I was
so shit-faced actually had the
after-dinner cigar first and then all of
a sudden he brought over like a pork
shoulder and I was smoking a cigar [ __ ]
I'd eat pork shoulder with my hands an
occasion I would look up and see
families walking by with children I'm
like I was just like wow man I remember
going to Sullivan Stadium back in the
day and seeing guys like me that's
amazing oh well quick so I got wasted
and by yourself what are you drinking
Jameson soda soda and she's are you face
in the room the bed still made right oh
no no I'm pacing the Cabana or the
Cabana that's a Cabana with no shirt
just shorts no shoes a hat and just a
drink in my left hand and then there's
other cabana next to us was all Patriots
fans they're all like big white dude Oh
Oh God but they were they were great
they were like nice guys cuz I I became
the MacLeod one obviously I became nuts
so there's one guy he was like to speak
that white dude the beard every time you
walk by the tango go pass I go yeah I
couldn't speak I'm just so like angry
I'm like yeah so at the end of it well
he's being a [ __ ] yeah I know he's being
a cut but he actually came in a big fat
white country yes exactly but he came
over and he was really cool he shook my
hand and congratulating me but by the
end of the game dude I lost it I started
throwing the flipping over the mouse
chairs oh god yeah you I because I was
just [ __ ] excited that's that's how I
get so I just flip it over do you think
that that Eagles fans are really that
bad or the rep was there so now they
just try to find the guy eating horse
[ __ ] you gotta admit horse shit's pretty
big all [ __ ] sports fans are bad
whole Eagles fans are pedestrian
compared to out here you get killed up a
guy got killed at a Dodgers game dude
Eagles playing they'll throw full beers
that you're the dumb point of your head
you want to get to a fistfight they'll
do that diet Billy farm animal [ __ ]
evidently in stab at a Raiders preseason
game like Raiders 49ers [ __ ] cares and
I'm so sick of the [ __ ] snowball
Santa who gives a [ __ ] you know I was
making fun of who gives up anytime you
guys are in a big game like the big
cheesy thing whenever Boston is in a big
game
what they talk about is they'll talk
about you know they'll show like [ __ ]
the paul revere statue or something in
north and all this [ __ ] that nobody from
boston ever went to unless you went on
some field trip that you that you
probably psyched as a kid cuz you have
to go to school the Freedom Trail and
the foliage and [ __ ] some lobster
fishermen tying a sailor's knot I don't
even know what I don't know what they do
you guys it's always you know what it is
what is it it's the rocky statue Philly
cheesesteak yes snowboy Santa I'm like
did you just say Pennsylvania is a
[ __ ] racial next time I go to Philly
next time I go to Philly I'm going to
going on one of those [ __ ]
cheesesteak places I'm gonna say this
hello I would like a Philadelphia Cream
Philadelphia cheesesteak sandwich with
peppers and onions and provolone cheese
please I'm so sick of them telling me
how to you got a winner
I'm not saying that so soup I have legal
tender make me a [ __ ] sandwich it's
the only city that's like that Oh in
Boston you want some clam chowder you
gotta go stupid I'm like I don't keep I
love Philly cheesesteaks I'm from
Bethlehem Pennsylvania I love them but I
don't love them enough to say this is
what I'm about I'm not a [ __ ] hoagie
can I tell you something - oh god I hate
clam chowder clam chowder tastes like it
was in you you know what it tastes like
no it isn't you know what is said [ __ ]
that cows chew when I'm in between their
three stomachs and they just yak and a
bowl that's what the [ __ ] it tastes like
you I like it's just to me what still
seems like it'd be clear every part of
the ocean would be foggy their eggs are
clear they got cleared kids I like I
like cream chowder and I don't even like
milky [ __ ] I'm like like those
intelligent I like my job but yeah I
know but it's not a big deal like Philly
cheesesteaks out it's just so [ __ ]
nuts and they show it cooking like I'm
cooking it never really ballgame what
kind of meat I actually been I liked I
really liked cheese sticks but I just
hate that whole [ __ ] that you gotta
say a dish way you know I don't I
haven't played Philly in so [ __ ] long
I don't know I've never you know any of
those places
yeah I stay away from I got it I gotta
tell you something a [ __ ] you know I
got this old truck so I listen to
[ __ ] AM radio so it's just this
sports talk somebody to speaking some
sort of Korean or like political [ __ ]
yeah yeah right-wing stuff so I'm listen
to this sports talk and they were
talking about that whatever that [ __ ]
whatever our coordinators name is Josh
or some [ __ ]
yeah you interviewed for the Colts job
oh all of that all of that [ __ ] and then
he walks away the last second and then
they're talking about it and this one
guy's going on closer you know there's
nothing not illegal Bart I don't like to
wait went down but blah blah and this
other guy on the show he goes this is
just indicative of the Patriots once
again bending the rules it's like you've
got to be [ __ ] me it's like the
level that people didn't pay attention
to deflategate it's like what that guy
did to us if that's all we do back to
let's just say that was a conspiracy
yeah okay Josh you're gonna go in there
even though we're preparing for the
Superbowl [ __ ] all of that we're gonna
have this big conspiracy then we're
gonna just waste their [ __ ] time if
that's all we did to them he got off
easy
he cost us a million dollars in two
draft picks over some [ __ ] you guys
deserve that why I'm [ __ ] with you
yeah all right but here's the thing with
the hoping you had a point I could
actually come to peace my favorite thing
with cherry on top that story the cherry
on top of that story is not that the
[ __ ] idiot found deflated balls on
the cold side too it's that the [ __ ]
guy in the cult's that caught the ball
the initial one that started all that
[ __ ] oh yeah that guy you know what
he didn't the next year the two years
within that he tested positive for
steroids
where was the ESPN there you you still
are mad you won the Super Bowl that year
like that no he didn't remember we
didn't before you talked about the
suspension or placate happened then and
then that then the next year like he got
[ __ ] suspended then they went to
court blah blah blah blah and then I got
a van and he got [ __ ] suspect laughed
out of court the judge was mad you
wasted a [ __ ] time then the NFL was
blood hurt that we beat him and then
they [ __ ] come back and they go out
is the NFL a corporation
yes is Tom Brady an employee of the
corporation
right to suspend an employee that's how
this is better and they found a loophole
Fanny got suspended like three years of
[ __ ] fair enough
but we wasted [ __ ] a week of that
guy's life and [ __ ] them over a season
[ __ ] that guy all right I don't like the
Colts I agree with you but you got a
super I don't like the Heat fans no fans
I don't would do we would have got the
[ __ ] Super Bowl anyways yeah yeah
yeah we know we did dunno you know and
then the 49ers went ahead to spend all
that money on a guy who's played five
games Oh
Garoppolo Jesus Christ I that what are
they doin gonna be good
you know he's gonna be good Garoppolo -
okay he looks like he's gonna do this
Vince I'm not saying he's not gonna be
good but dude that guy's making more
money than like Aaron Rodgers III you
know I do disagree with you Tom Brady
would not have played as well if he
didn't get suspended those first four
games two years ago I listen I will say
this I liked a 39 four-year-old guy
getting four games off like that's great
but I don't think it added anymore dude
he's like psycho driven anyways my only
think about him is I don't want him to
go out like Brett Favre
I don't cuz this whole [ __ ] thing tom
versus time if he plays least 45 you
know as long as he's still competitive I
just don't want to see him like on the
Rams like Joe Namath [ __ ] Johnny
Unitas wearing a [ __ ] Chargers
universe two eyebrows he's too proud he
won't I hope he doesn't do that why the
[ __ ] is he doing this weird reality show
I don't get it what it what is I'm not
gonna pay attention to him but that
makes me [ __ ] nervous because he
never did I mean Peyton Manning did like
400 commercials a year I thought that
helped us yeah because Peyton is kinda
like to every guy like he comes off like
a dumb farmer I mean people like that
[ __ ] Midwest I [ __ ] I can't I don't
like the Colts in general I don't like
to have to beat the Chargers that's what
I would have sunk somebody asked me
today like eight you know what where
does uh where does it's this is just
gonna be all football talk where does
where does uh you know Tom Brady having
the greatest coach of all time in the in
the brave versus Peyton Manning argument
and that's a fair point but I be honest
with you I actually liked Eli I would
rather have had Eli in January yeah
Eli's a better playoff quarterback than
Eli his brothers instinct in
september/october but then when you know
I need him to turn visage turns it on
damn marina don't you say pay man he's
the greatest regular-season quarterback
of all time
first of all Dan Marino gets an
unbelievable bad rap okay Peyton Manning
was part of a three-headed [ __ ]
monster alrighty one that's a rule no
just like Edgerrin James and and and
what's-his-face their wide receiver just
forgot his [ __ ] name Marvin Marvin
Harrison I never had his football card
so I'll never remember Lee guy all right
no he didn't he alleged alleged alleged
maybe the alias horseshit he was upset
they [ __ ] Dan Marino had no running
game and no defense yes great his entire
career what was he supposed to do I'll
tell you around Tom Brady would not have
won a [ __ ] Super Bowl with wit [ __ ]
and Don Shula everybody stole all this
tricks by the time that dude damn arena
would have thrown easily for 6,000 yards
in today's NFL yeah do you like it no no
I'm I don't like it they went too far
and what I'm liking about watching these
first Super Bowls is I like more the
running I like the deep defenses had
nicknames and stuff it was it was a
meaner game and it was a more strategic
game and do Paul Bercy said the funniest
[ __ ] [ __ ] about that
Eagles Patriots Super Bowl he's like
dude he goes that's the kind that's the
kind of game your girlfriend likes yeah
yeah like if soccer had that much boring
I'd be like dude that was a great
[ __ ] game and all those English guys
would be like whoa I made it [ __ ]
baby they would be able to break down
the game as to why it sucked everyone
keeps telling me what a great game
congratulations I'm happy because the
Eagles want I'm happy but it wasn't it
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] wasn't a great game
there was no [ __ ] defense as I said
it was view
friendly yeah it was but and I have to
be honest with you that is all those
rule changes I always blame Jim Irsay
cuz I'm a [ __ ]
but it's all of them it's because
they're trying to expand the game and
you know that they've done studies and
you know that offense sells the game
that's why I think MLB looked the other
way when everyone was all roided up and
they actually act surprised all the
owners get to act surprised like oh we
had no [ __ ] idea I really like we
don't know the comics that are partying
yeah the MLB doesn't you paid a guy a
zillion dollars a [ __ ] year you don't
know what he's doing but it's like the
NBA but that game was [ __ ] that bet
when they had the strike and they didn't
have the World Series and all of that
[ __ ] they needed something to come back
by the way that was a [ __ ] awesome
ear though it was [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
amazing I remember Washington College
every lunch everywhere in the cafeteria
we'd watch the [ __ ] highlights like
who I went to like I never I went to uh
Mark McGwire his 27th or 28th homerun it
was down in San Diego almost when
they're still playing in Qualcomm
Stadium
I went there with this Boston Common Dan
Smith and we were sat in the upper
Decker when [ __ ] McGuire do but the
place was packed for his uh for his when
he would take batting practice and the
whole place he came up to the plate for
batting practice standing ovations it
was like three quarters amazing for
everybody doesn't this a funny [ __ ] ever
the first pitch in he laid down a bunt
and everybody booed and then he laughed
and everybody laughed because it was
kind of a cool way to get rid of the
stress it let me I got to read a couple
of little advertisements here and then I
want to talk about what's going on with
mailboxes all right I'm gonna talk to
you about it all right the black tux
everybody Kevin this is the black tux
the but like the Ohio State you heard I
got the Greg Wilson V Greg Wilson
I love the Greg Wilson Greg he's a nut
bag yeah he's the best
everyone wants to look as great as their
date at a wedding or special event now
they're talking about wearing a dress
trouble is there's no way you want to
spend the amount of time or money she
did shopping for her outfit I can't read
out loud by the way V black box comm is
your answer with high quality rental
suits and tuxedos delivered to your
doorstep the black tux is the easy way
for
to rent suits and tuxedos online suits
usually retail for 1,200 bucks
but at black tux they start at just 95
dollars
mmm goddamn huh I'm gonna get a tuxedo
wearing on my podcast expert customer
care has you has your back every step of
the way completely done online with the
black tux free home try on you can see
the fit and feel the quality of your
suit months before your event after
ordering your suit after ordering your
suit will arrive 14 days before your
event if anything else is less than
perfect be black tux we'll send you a
free replacement right away when your
events over just drop your rental back
in the mail that's gross shipping is
free both ways big manila envelope
uh-hmm
to get $20 off your purchase visit black
dogs black tux car first
that's the black tux calm slash birth
for $20 off your purchase B black tux
Premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered I love when people laughed at
my reads one it's it's too hard to say
what is that the black talks VB black
that's why you got to go you got to chop
it up deep black tux Jewish fur here's
another one here's another simply safe I
know this I've got some exciting news
simply safe a home security company I've
worked with since there's we they were a
startup who the [ __ ] was this for I've
watched them transform into that why do
they do this okay look they've
transformed into the fastest-growing
home security company in the nation
protecting over two million people while
they just released their brand-new home
security system they all new simply safe
now this is the [ __ ] I'm into you got to
have a home security system at this
point right I don't understand what they
do you don't understand what they do I
mean I'm glad you asked you'd be great
on an infomercial wait a minute
but does the H stick to the pan of
course not just watch Kevin this system
has been completely completely rebuilt
and redesigned they've added new
safeguards to protect against power
outages downed Wi-Fi cut landlines bats
hammers and everything in between
remember the underscarf
face yeah yeah yeah you know he wasn't
doing all that blow that was a simply
safe system and they saw all those
[ __ ] people coming over the wall but
Tony was too busy partying Tony what do
you want the [ __ ] meet Tony the all-new
simply safe was redesigned to be
practically invisible with the powerful
sensors so small you'll hardly notice
them you know who will intruders this is
what's truly remarkable to me evidently
simply safe spent years building the
system they added so much more how weird
was that [ __ ] scene that that poor
actress had to play you want to [ __ ] me
Tony those hot now you know why you have
a private computer for point but you'll
still get the same fair honest price
24/7 protection for only 15 bucks a
month and there's no contract it's
smaller faster and stronger than
anything they've built before but the
supply is very limited visit simply safe
duck burst Jesus visit simply safe BRR
calm now to order that simply safe bird
calm to protect your home and family
today simply safe bird calm one more can
you can you sit here I like it
can I interrupt me no no no you listen
to Howard Stern a little bit I like I
don't like I like stamps calm stamps are
calm is easiest is the easiest way to
access all the amazing services of the
post office print postage for any mail
class right from your own computer the
exact amount of postage every time never
under pay or over pay again stamps calm
saves you time and money which you can
use to grow your business I can mail any
letter any package using my computer and
my printer and the mailman comes and
picks it up the mailman the hashtag Mito
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips tips highest print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer they'll send that
you a digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage stamps comm
will even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your business needs I
use stamps comm whenever I send out my
posters I pour myself I love Stan Alden
groped by [ __ ] Cougars that never
never
never they brought - how to drive -
stamps um well I don't know you [ __ ]
use a computer you have your assistant
to it that's what you do actually and
right now
you too can enjoy something somebody
born in the 90s you have do it and right
now you too can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
in a digital sale scale go to stamps.com
clip on the microphone on top of the
homepage type in bird that stamps comm
enter peruse your computer in your
printer that's how you do it I love a
printer then you use you know a printer
runner alright you know you went
negative on all the ads getting a talk
you don't need a home security system
and everything I'll need Ohio State
email [ __ ]
I don't mail [ __ ] I return the only time
I ever mail [ __ ] have to return a [ __ ]
how do you pay bills alright you pay
online yeah and do you use like your
banking online yeah do you not do that
no do you do not [ __ ] mail checks all
the time you're [ __ ] with me no do
you know do so you need so wait we'll
hold it I'm one of the last ones because
one's gonna say there's no [ __ ] they're
starting to get rid of mailboxes they're
starting to weld them shut you go up to
one you're like oh good and then you
can't get it in there what yeah they're
going away like remember those dos those
phone booths the big red phone booths
that they had in England yes and now for
some reason they sold all of them over
here because we're weird and we want to
so they turn those are the new mailboxes
I think I think a bunch of you in
England are gonna buy our old post
office boxes and someone just to come in
their man caves so one just bought the
LA Times so how the [ __ ] are we gonna
get the LA Times if there's mail boxes
don't work don't you have a paper boy I
don't know there's no paper boy yeah
yeah I do see I see uh Mexican moms
driving their kids around in the
mornings in the mornings and they fill
their [ __ ] paper and god bless him my
dad used to do this with us that's why I
have the workout I had I had a paper in
from third grade till the point it got
weird yeah that my voice was starting to
change I couldn't walk away from the
money all my friends were always broke I
do it I had no overhead football cards
and candy with my biggest [ __ ]
expenses so that was it I wish it'd be
great if we just I used to ride my bike
up to the bowling alley go bowling I
paid for the
whole [ __ ] thing no ya never had to
go to my parent hey man you owe me a
couple of bucks man never had to do that
I was [ __ ] independent will you go
bill
I'm going on a bike ride all right get
the [ __ ] out of here they didn't give a
[ __ ] we would we were bowling and you
were but you were exhausted at school I
guarantee you I wasn't oh you were up at
like 4:00 in the morning I wrote a bike
I didn't go boozing cuz I was a kid my
but my body was brand-new all right
premier league football people write in
they ask questions in all this [ __ ] like
this premier league football Premier
League if I swear to God the level of
excitement like whenever I put these
games on every time when I watch him
like you know they love it I can get
into it it's always like nighttime and
[ __ ] no it makes you want to booze you
wish it was cold I you stuck on half I
got my scarf I start singing some song I
hate to be the cliche American but I
don't sir william of albino phil-billy
red Ted say you're freckled [ __ ] you
know it's usually I like that sir albino
bill that's almost begging for a picture
I think I got to dress up in a regal way
I got to make sure we wrap this up
because I'm gonna go see Todd Rex's Rex
yep and he sold out both of his shows
oversold them so thank you to everybody
listen to Todd on this show and bought a
ticket
all right there is only one team you can
support in the English Premier League
and that is Liverpool I'm just gonna
pause and wait for everybody in England
listen oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Beatlemania it is deeply working-class
with a long Irish history all right I'm
in the city itself doesn't consider
itself English but a separate entity
from the rest of the country Oh
grow the [ __ ] up what are you the south
you're gonna secede from the union
Liverpool Football Club is currently
owned by Fenway Sports Group yeah that's
the Red Sox is it yeah up until recently
we were the most successful team in
England but a barren spell due to
tragedy and mismanagement finally seems
to be coming to an end
much like the Red Sox during their
winless run so why the [ __ ] do I want to
jump on the bandwagon now
we had the most exciting attacking line
in the league possibly Europe our
manager is an utter lunatic a very rich
history okay I'm kind of in right now
not all of it is good
including 18 league titles and five
European Cups the best team in the whole
of Europe is the European Cup
we've been targeted by the press the
media and even the government oh this is
like the Patriots let us see I'm a
[ __ ] Liverpool fan this isn't a
franchise bill once you pick your team
or once your team picks you that's it
for life no changing no moving cities
through good and bad up the Reds Billy
Boy hey I don't switch teams
don't even [ __ ] suggest that I do
that you [ __ ] [ __ ] but uh yeah I I
was gonna pick Liverpool just because I
like the Beatles he was just trying to
get you to switch to Liverpool my
favorite Beatle song of all time are we
we are isn't we we are the Beatles all
right views do you get into soccer at
all a little bit a little bit World Cup
World Cups kind of fun except for that
one year in Africa when he has I don't
know that instrument of like a kazoo
[ __ ] up bagpipe and Yoko Ono played it
views on public speaking fees hey Bill
longtime fan and listener and I always
enjoy your point of view one thinks that
he just went straight ahead there you go
anyways was listening to the most recent
Monday morning podcast and I was
surprised to hear your point of view on
speaking fees considering that you are
in sit in essence a public speaker I
guess that you have some understanding
how much more money this is relative to
other named acts I would be curious to
see how much money other famous people
get to talk if you knew those without
naming names apparently Obama gets 400
grand per speech no I'm not a public
speaker I'm a comedian yeah you know I
mean at that point like somebody going
like you know extracts read all about it
I don't like the ones who like
motivational speakers yeah that there's
a reason that someone's called a public
speaker
because they're boring and they're not
funny you're called a committee director
you entertaining it's like TED talk yeah
no my problem that I had with these guys
say like Obama where everybody's looking
at this guy like he's a [ __ ] Saint
yeah is he's doing what all of these
guys do they all go into public office
they say they're there for the people
and by the by the end of his like
administration he was already worth 80
million dollars when he was making like
four or five hundred grand a year but
she gotta make some wants to make money
no yeah but I mean they should give the
president [ __ ] you money I'm not
obsessing it's the fact that I don't
have the money to be like a Obama well
okay Trump when you get an office make
sure the comedy club always has fresh
calamari
here's [ __ ] ten million bucks you
know what I mean yeah like they do
except they do it on a [ __ ] global
level is he asking how much performers
get paid I don't know what he's I don't
know what the [ __ ] he's asking on the
flip side should we even care how much
money they get after they're out of
office sir yes all you have to do how
does the president get into office how
does he afford to get into office he
needs people to make campaign donations
all right and when these [ __ ] rich
people make the donations and then after
after they're done and he does
everything that they want to then they
go on the tour that's them washing their
bribe money yeah hey I'm gonna give you
a four in a grand to give an hour-long
speech yeah the whole disabilties
yeah it's it's it's so [ __ ] out
that's what it is I'm not I'm not upset
this guy I'm not upset that anyone can
go out and make money it's just the fact
that you got these guys they need a
hundred million dollars to get a job
that pays for five hundred grand a year
and before the G they're making five
hundred grand a year and by the end of
it they are they're already worth like
eighty million bucks like how the [ __ ]
did that happen does that happen how
does that how the [ __ ] does that happen
cuz it's all [ __ ] corrupt um that's
my problem sir and I think the only
truth like really decent like truly
public servant that I've seen as a as a
president in my lifetime was Jimmy
Carter I'm not saying he didn't go out
and do public speeches I didn't look up
to that but the guy has spent his he's
golden years when he could just be
sitting there
thing like [ __ ] George Bush you know
he could be out there tagging broads
like when he's ePHI his [ __ ] building
he's for the home isn't he shaking hands
on an airplane - he's a [ __ ] great
dude is that the guy yeah yeah you know
what's funny you know what's funny he
was the most human you must humane guy
I've seen and and he was considered to
be an absolute [ __ ] but we know that's
the truth that's how it works
you can't be nice and not be considered
a puss know you could be you could be
that you can be a decent you can be
decent thing about it is is he was nice
enough when that whole [ __ ] Iran [ __ ]
what the hostages went down he settled
that without getting dragged into a war
so he's considered a [ __ ] because big
business could have gone in there and
made that money you know yeah that's
kind of not have to whatever another
event to go in there and try to get a
bunch of [ __ ] oil yeah all right
cheating with a boyfriend like these
here we go hey Billy BRR it's cold
shall we [ __ ] no no no that's making fun
of my last night oh okay that takes me
back to like grade school all right I'm
a female I got a lady right nin by the
way dude you're a [ __ ] great guest
man and you're a [ __ ] great comedian
Kevin J you got Kevin Shea and listen to
the old [ __ ] don't lie wait wait wait
alls I'm saying I'm saying oh no that's
all I'm saying and were you performing
next
oh I'm at the ice house Tuesday give me
a [ __ ] paid gig man oh [ __ ]
West Palm Beach this weekend but that's
I'm with Ken Jeong Jeong all right the
guy from there you go there you go the
improv yeah West Palm Beach improv yeah
you go there you go to Kevin shade calm
go to camera shade that TV some dark and
white guy in upper upstate New York has
given [ __ ] Oh Kevin shade TBS and go
down check him out he's [ __ ]
hilarious all right bill I'm a female
the story isn't about me it's about my
friend that's a lie I know my friend
wants to [ __ ] around on our husband
we're in our early 20s and have been
friends since high school we've always
been there for each other and even
our friendship has been long it has been
long-distance since then however now we
have a slight problem she's been dating
a guy for a year and they've been
butting heads lately one night she got
high with her roommate who's a guy and
they started to kiss and then of course
one thing led to another
apparently her roommate has been having
feelings for her for a long time and
wants to be in a relationship with her
instead of just banging her she broke up
with her boyfriend
using their conflicts as the reason
instead of saying she cheated all three
of them have been have a bunch of mutual
friends so she wants to lay low on the
fact that she cheated she also wants to
give her now ex-boyfriend time to heal
before he finds out she's dating a
roommate this is called being a class
act
why bring extra hurt right yeah but why
not I mean at this point if she's
feeling guilty just [ __ ] say it that
is easy to say at our age but when
you're young yeah okay when you're
younger you don't know how to do it she
doesn't even have she doesn't even know
that it's obviously her that's right
let's keep going here I keep trying to
tell her that would be better to come
clean about what she's done now than to
wait it out I know whatever there
whatever that gender I know people in
whatever that Jenna had the ability to
cheat growing up I've seen how being
cheated on has affected people around me
including myself I never thought that
she would be the person to cheat so my
question is why people cheat whatever
and then like now she's judging her so
my question is how can I get it through
her head and she needs to handle this
situation better but also be a good
friend to her at the same time if nee is
there and has an advice it would be
great thanks ago [ __ ] just [ __ ]
yourself a second date problem no this
is a different one you know what I think
you need to butt out
yeah what okay if we if we actually
think this isn't about her which I don't
I think it's about her and someone
saying that to her yeah yeah so if it's
if it's you if this is actually what a
worded it that way I believe it okay if
we believe it it's none of your [ __ ]
business you know people make mistakes
we're all human
you're in so if you're if you
good this is the action if you're a real
[ __ ] friend you wouldn't judge her
can I tell you something that once you
get past the pain she did you a favor
yeah cuz you know you weren't married
didn't have any [ __ ] kids you didn't
have a house together and all that so
who gives a [ __ ] and then she you know
they were already butting heads they
weren't getting along was the and I get
and there were 22 that it's already over
relationship and you go [ __ ] somebody I
mean it's done girls you know what
that's lights like an empty-net goal you
know what I mean no plot it but I mean
you know you didn't fake out a goal
that's it's garbage time they got all
the start is on the bench it's garbage
time it's garbage time [ __ ] you know
what you have you ever that's it I've
done it I've done oh god I found out
later that you do me I got man I should
say [ __ ] it was over it was over it's
one more than not whatever time you're
in a relationship is it was over a half
like here in four years that's been done
for two years does that make sense
well I would say a year and a half here
and a half breakups just don't happen
overnight you don't wake over like you
know I'm [ __ ] out of here you draw it
out you start to get distance you start
fishing see a [ __ ] course you know
how to break up in high school honey in
high school I should I should teach
young people how to do it it would be so
much better I think just so you don't
[ __ ] drag someone or you don't get
dragged along all you had to do is you
just got to sit down I mean one time I
had to get out of relationship and it
was Steve Byrne had just got out of one
this was like [ __ ] you know years ago
20 25 years ago right and that's 25 like
20 years ago and I literally asked him I
was like what did you say goes I just
sat down and said I just said I'm not
happy that's what he started with and
I've given that advice on here because I
used that and never told me I just
[ __ ] used it I don't how many we need
though I'm just not like yeah I just you
know it's it's just not working it just
doesn't feel right I'm not happy yeah
and this is thing but this is thing you
have to get it all out yeah and I think
we should break up
and you got it you'd like I think you
just go bump bump it's like monkey bars
boom boom boom get across it and then
you say we gotta break up oh she's gonna
drag you through it like 50 [ __ ] times
it's like lying to the cops you just
stick talking story
yeah it's but that whole I'm not happy
I've heard it I've said it
it usually drags out for seven more
months no no but that's you it's no
we're not happy it's not working out we
need to break up you know I want to
break up what the [ __ ] it's done yeah no
I get it I get it but it never works
that way usually the other person's like
no we can work this out then that's when
you have to go al Madrigal listen if you
are living together yeah if you're
living to get hard then it's hard then
you're not living together you have to
go al Madrigal what now unless I don't
never told you that no I don't know dude
al had a breakup one time this chick had
some [ __ ] at his house
he knew he was gonna break up with her
before he broke up he said he told her
hey I'm gonna come over tonight I think
we need to talk about some things so
she's like okay he [ __ ] got a box
packed all his [ __ ] up that was at his
apartment walked over set the box down
and said we got to break up it's not
working dude it was [ __ ] clean yeah
over that's that's easy for out cos Al's
a [ __ ] maniac like he does he when he
hasn't learned from maniacs no I love
maniacs I'm kind of a maniac I want
I am calm amazing a psycho but it does a
psycho when it comes to breaking up
they've never been good no good that's
why you got to get through it if you
live with them is harder if you don't
live with them it's easy and that's why
people [ __ ] hang in and then they
start cheating and they're doing all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] because they're
basically mentally broken up so that
woman they're essentially didn't even
like as far as like and on an emotional
level yeah didn't [ __ ] on a physical
level she cheated but unemotional of her
she didn't because she already [ __ ]
broke up with the guy she was done she
yeah I find that when he's done they're
done here's one here's one when you know
the other person was already [ __ ]
other people okay when you someone
breaks up with you and they're not even
crying like that means they're ready
cried it out with their [ __ ] friends
they got no tears left and it's just
like wow man this how long is this [ __ ]
yeah you know I've never cried
to break up I can't and they get guys
don't cry get all the girl all my
ex-girlfriend all my ex-girlfriends
ex-boyfriend they're like they cry they
cry cuz they're [ __ ] I'll gonna say
the other words so I'm glad I did it but
this I would have known what it this is
how I know this is how I know this is
how I know when it's done when they
don't kiss you good-bye in the morning
like cuz I don't get off work this is
how I know it's done when when they're
mad at you and you don't give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah like kiss and they come in and
they start doing the cold shoulder
you're like and they're not [ __ ] you
it's a sect any like good no you're
right
you're right because then you start
getting more productive because you got
so much mental time oh there's nothing
worse than getting dumped but if you're
the one breaking up with some dude I've
been on both sides I've broken hearts
I've had my heart broken it's brutal
it's brutal I think that's why I'm so
numb to it all now yeah
just [ __ ] numb oh no I already know
if my marriage never worked out I would
never get married again
and I would just give my wife [ __ ]
everything and then I would just go live
in a [ __ ] trailer
my buddy I'm not doing it again
I'm not getting on the [ __ ] ride
again yeah that's it now just [ __ ]
wherever she lives I'll just drive the
trailer down the street so I can still
see my kid you can send in one of those
ear pods don't get a [ __ ] I buy one
of those VW buses no I get a studio I
get all the sports packages that would
be it I know electronic drum kit I just
go back to what the [ __ ] I had I'm
actually shocked that you got married to
be oz of you best thing I ever did I
only is great but it's weird as I don't
know I don't know if I'm ever getting
married to be honest it's like I want to
get married but I love I'll choose
you'll do it when you're ready
yeah I'm 42 I wasn't married I got
married 45 I got three more years I mean
it's great and then all of a sudden I'm
like five years in I'm already gonna
turn 50 what the [ __ ] am I going
actually where am I going
we're gonna go back to [ __ ] there's a
club this way ladies you're looking for
a bald redhead
it's so sad I saw I see comics like that
Oh believe me dude that was a motivation
I'm not gonna be the cliche it's so
[ __ ] sad I was like oh god I don't so
sad I'm like dating I don't I don't I
can't tell you I haven't dated since I
started doing stand-up really does that
makes any sense like I meet girls and
then we just start hanging out and then
I sent and picking them that sounds
weird you start why we start hanging out
that I just picked them I was like oh
this is the one I'm when I'm out with
this one for a while do they know that's
what you're doing I don't know if they
do yeah you need to just this is the
best thing I haven't [ __ ] learned is
you just got to [ __ ] say what you're
thinking yeah yeah you know that's one
of the reason most of the women that I
did like me cuz I pretty much say what
I'm thinking that's all how happy would
you be if a woman did that it'd be
[ __ ] amazing
I'm not saying like hey you look ugly
today I'm not saying no I mean like you
know I don't don't be me but like just
say do that one more time
I thought of watershed moment my
relationship was they had one of her
friends was having a [ __ ] birthday
party Yeah right the same night the
Celtics and Lakers were playing like
Game six of the NBA Finals
okay she's like what are you doing
Tuesday she doesn't talk like that that
just how it sounds in my head so she so
I'm like I'm watching the game she's
like mmm
does the pouty face you know the
manipulation I hate that sexy voice and
then the pout right so she's already
tried to [ __ ] tactics and not only is
a friend having a birthday party it's
like some [ __ ] 1920s themed birthday
party so I have to buy a [ __ ] costume
a flapper yeah I get a dress like I'm in
the Purple Gang or some [ __ ] right so
she goes do you want to go and I just I
said no I like that I like that yeah
just what do you mean no she goes why
not I go that sounds horrific yeah she
goes she laughed she goes marry mate she
goes she's a friend of you as I go no
she isn't I go she's your friend I've
become friendly with her because you
know her yeah but she's not my friend I
was sick this week she didn't
oh she didn't call she's not my friend I
just kept I just kept saying no and the
more I said no the more she thought it
was funny but she got frustrated then
she just started laughing like I'm not
going [ __ ] down there dressed like
Charlie Chaplin I want to watch this
game I don't want to [ __ ] do this so
then she was like and she just she goes
what time does the game start I go
you're such a [ __ ] so now I got to go
to this [ __ ] party then race back so
then I just made a compromise I said
alright the game [ __ ] starts you let
at whatever I said here's the deal
I go I will drive you there I will make
an appearance I'm not dressing up and
I'm leaving with plenty of [ __ ] time
to get back yeah
so the before the game starts yeah all
right now I don't want to hear that once
again that's not how she sounds that's
how she sounds when she says [ __ ] like
that
so she said fine so I [ __ ] show up I
drop this thing off on a shelf there's
all these [ __ ] guys they dress like
[ __ ] Charlie Chaplin and Al Capone
and [ __ ] and I come walking in with like
a [ __ ] Celtic shirt on dressed all
regular they say hey you didn't dress up
I said no no I'm getting out of here in
like 10 minutes
there they go where you gonna go I'm
gonna watch the Celtics game and it's
the finals
that's [ __ ] and I remember the look on
their faces and I mistakenly I felt
awesome
they they were so jealous dude you know
what I do I've you know many times have
been the guy in the [ __ ] Chaplin
outfit alright you know I've always been
pretty hard about saying no look I'll
just say no yeah I mean but then I'd
pretty good about compromise though if
they want to do something important to
them so as long as I get to do what I
want and then if they have something I
know I have a bunch of compromises I
have the okay but you're driving and I'm
drinking I go to brunch if you drive and
I can drink that's the thing yeah do you
know that I still don't I still don't I
don't do brunch yeah that's the one
thing I [ __ ] every time they walk
there's a line and then they walk in
they come on they go it's gonna be 40
minutes all right dude no it's not
alright this is my [ __ ] day too and
it's a Sunday [ __ ] it's just I'm
actually gonna get pissed dude what the
[ __ ] do we take
two on a weekend where we walk out be
like if they said it's gonna be 40
minutes they would lose their [ __ ] okay
what Bailey which they won't lose their
[ __ ] house [ __ ] they would pop they
would pop alright so I have time to read
how far into this are we [ __ ] alright
hour and 20 we got to wrap this up I'll
read the rest of these some other time
Kevin this was effortless oh thank you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] this is obviously
funny and everybody should go out to the
Improv and West Palm West Palm Beach
more importantly listen to the podcast
and listen to the podcast all I'm saying
all I'm saying podcast we can't even say
one of the funniest dudes for the
longest [ __ ] time
all right everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on ya on Thursday